la pluie s'est mise de la partie quand
les petits chanteurs du primaire ont
traversé la rue pour rejoindre leurs
aînés en face du collège notre dame
cette proximité entre l'oratoire
saint-joseph l'école de la maîtrise et
le collège privé où les plus âgés font
leurs études secondaires est essentiel
au quotidien donc ce sera pratique donc
si on change d'école on en haut du col
plus loin sa devront plus compliquée
depuis que la commission scolaire de
montréal a décidé du transfert des
élèves du secondaire à l'académie de
roberval
près de 90% des parents ont manifesté
leur intention de retirer leurs enfants
du choeur jean françois baudet parents
d'un élève est lui même ex petit
chanteur il songe c'est un
fonctionnement qui existe depuis
longtemps et donc de briser ce cycle
armand brésil modèle des chanteurs ici
c'est une des choses majeures qui a pas
été comprise ici par la csdm
malheureusement
l'enterrement est symbolique mais une
probabilité si rien n'est fait croit le
directeur musical
normalement on a débordé mais à des
missions et à des démissions des
familles qui veulent pas embarquer dans
cet avenir qui est pas clair d'autres
anciens sont venus demander
l'intervention du ministre de
l'éducation
c'est une institution qui risquent de
ceux de terre du pied plus tôt par que
ça s'arrête parce qu'on va perdre nos
amis lesquels va être terminé on pourra
plus chanter faire les prestations le
cabinet de jean françois roberge
maintient que le passage des petits
chanteurs à l'école publique doit être
fait dans des conditions qui assurent la
pérennité des petits chanteurs il ajoute
nous sommes inquiets de l'avenir des
petits chanteurs une intervention de
notre part ne peut être exclu à ce stade
ci tant que ministre lit peuvent faire
ces actions mais au niveau de la csdm
on offre la poursuite au secondaire à
l'académie de roberval
[Applaudissements]
plusieurs arts en août encore l'espoir
que des ministres de l'éducation et de
la culture sauve les petits chanteurs du
mont royal
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal